we're on the road to 2020 this morning
with less than a year now to go before
the presidential election polls show the
nation remains starkly divided on
impeachment the latest Fox News poll
shows 49 percent of voters want
President Trump
removed from office four percent say he
should be impeached but not removed and
41 percent oppose impeachment but will
the inquiry have any bearing on how
Americans vote next November at O'Keefe
is in Iowa where the first in the nation
caucuses will be held in less than three
months Ned what are Motors telling you
about impeachment well good morning
Anthony from New Hampshire to
Mississippi Nevada to here in Iowa we've
been talking to voters in recent days
about those upcoming elections and like
those polls they're mostly split but
they're not focused on impeachment
they're more concerned about other
issues in Washington right now they're
consumed by impeachment
what do you think gonna happen on that
issue
I think they're doing the exact right
thing I trust Nancy Pelosi and then
gathering more information that's he
pulls he's got a desk full of things
that she could be working on they're
taking all their time with the craziness
I think it's a bunch of made-up stuff
they're trying to impeach Donald truck
they have no grounds he's broken no law
you're thinking about who they pick what
are the sort of 1 or 2 most important
issues for you climate change is one of
the most important issues for me I think
the minimum wage because there are too
many people working too many jobs so I
definitely think education a lot of
candidates are talking about student
loan forgiveness the cost of higher ed I
can't think of anything in the United
States that's going right you know in
terms of it's all broken how the country
is so polarized right now people get
angry there's people you know
threatening other people over politics
there are be a safety net there are
beats where people can't get insurance
from life insurance they have there
aren't to be a place for them to do a
public option how closely are you paying
attention to this go around as opposed
to maybe years past I want to hear where
both sides are coming from because you
can't make an informed decision just
listening to one side now from all the
people we spoke with there's still no
consensus on who they're voting for
some said they still want to hear from
all the candidates and with 17 Democrats
and 4 Republicans running for president
that means they've got a lot of
listening to do Gayle lots of people
talking thank you very much ad